I seem fun the diary of Jen Kirkman
podcast it's the week before Christmas
episode which is the more fun than
Christmas itself this this is the best
week of the year in my opinion episode
214 comin at you in the all things
comedy studio I am here this says I've
been good I think the other side says
something else I know it says I've been
good I've been good I have actually been
really good this year
good behaving and good feeling before we
get started this episode's brought to
you by quip Rent the Runway and talk
space will tell you all about that later
last minute gift ideas people I was
gonna bring my books and hold them up
and I I put the books under my laptop
which with my purse over that so that I
would not forget in the morning and I
grabbed my laptop with my purse and I
don't grab the books
I don't want doing that but my books are
for sale I barely I can't even remember
the titles I can barely take care of
myself
a great book about the the decision or
the just fact that I didn't have kids
and people all getting up I'm a business
about it and I think it's a great book
to give to someone who doesn't have kids
and you know when the book came out I
thought well everyone's bought it what's
that's not true
I haven't even made a profit on it yet
so clearly everyone has not bought it so
and it wasn't York Times bestseller
that's just how that goes I can barely
take care of myself it is on paperback
its on Kindle hardcover you can gift it
any of those ways when you go to Amazon
don't buy it new and don't buy it from
the used people that money doesn't go to
me there's people profiting off me it's
so gross I hate it and then I know what
I'm doing another lies I tell myself
that is another book you can get that
ever but more importantly my necklace
line with bauble bar oh my god my one of
my necklaces felt oh no it didn't goes
away December 31st
this one says over 40 now some of them
are more expensive you can get a fancy
over 41 this is like a hundred bucks
real gold and you can also get an over
for anyone that looks like this that's
more acrylic but you have the option and
then one that says child free that's
also kind of a fancies and then feminist
AF come on ladies ladies you know you
want one go to Jen Kirkman comment
to write on my homepage go to bauble bar
BAU ble bar comm and I'm search my name
and I'm gonna take a picture of myself
and post it so okay lots been going on
this week I want to talk a little bit
about the possibility of Trump firing
Muller or Rosenstein what I think about
everyone's hysteria my Christmas in New
York I'm gonna read an article I wrote
for the Guardian UK London newspaper no
big deal international writer but I know
they're gonna chop it down cuz they
wanted it to be short so I'll read you
the whole thing about reclaiming
Christmas I leave this week from a trip
to New York City
I'm so [ __ ] excited I can't stand it
now I should tell you guys well we'll
get into it later I'm gonna get into the
New York stuff later because it's like
deeper and you know my whole thing so
let's start with what I was going to
start with and and I I told Aaron Auer
on about it oh by the way I have a four
part I have a it's big fancy time on the
TuneIn app sorry I shouldn't be
advertising this at TuneIn t un e en is
powered by Amazon echo I hosted a four
part series the holiday survival podcast
this week's is about relationships
whether you're in one how to survive and
whether or not last week's was about no
for the holidays meaning you don't do
the holidays and and what that's like
and the week before is about dealing
with family so I interview top celebs
and friends of mine and sometimes
they're both about how they do things
and it was put together beautifully it
sounds like one of those like NPR things
I think the jazzy music and they're like
next up you know so you can listen to
that mmm if you go to the facebook.com
slash I seem fun podcast page I put all
the tune in info there as well as on my
Facebook page facebook.com or you can go
to just Google tune in holiday Survival
Guide Jen Kirkman or go to my Twitter at
Jen Kirkman and you'll find it okay
folks I'm not sick
I've got acid reflux up the badoom which
I don't know why I've been dairy-free
you know what it is I had some red sauce
last night that's when
Julia all right Aaron I have a story
about how easy I shopped local and it
really bit me in the ass pursuant to an
earlier conversation we had about cheese
and bread in Italy I brought I bought
Aaron a little holiday gift of I don't
even know what it is cheese with
truffles it's some big fancy Italian
cheese imported cost $4,000 thank you
very much mm-hmm so I go to this um
local cheese shop in my neighborhood and
my neighborhood is so [ __ ] cute you
can't even take it it is in Studio City
I shouldn't tell you too much where I
live but it's not like right where my
place is but it's yeah this little strip
of cute shops I mean they're all
independently owned little vintage
stores antique stores cheese shops
restaurants cafes gelato
I mean it's so hallmark movie I'm in
heaven all the time I walk up and down
it every night it's just about a block
and a half you don't see a lot of stuff
like that in LA and I am in the valley
which is not quite the city but it's
very close to the city it's it's it's
closer to the action than like say if
you looked at the beach okay so I go
into this place and I'm like can I get
this cheese now everyone's a shop local
blah blah I walk in I'm like ooh this
looks really good they're like do you
want to try anything I'm like oh no I
can't eat dairy right now but I know
when I want this this guy just got back
from Italy he enjoyed the cheese so
something that's really from Italy I
think oh well there's this one but you
know it it's come pricier than the other
ones I know I'm not saying this say I
spent $4,000 but it was probably more of
like $4,800 and so she says uh she says
I said well okay well what's the price
they don't tell me the price for like 45
minutes Sun setting you know my nails
are growing I'm like just tell me the
goddamn prep how are you you want be
able to shop local and yet
you're steering them away from things so
I go that's fine I don't this is a young
girl so you know what I mean shouldn't
know she's dealing with a grown woman
corporatist coastal elite coming in so
then she goes um so then they go do you
want a gift bag I go oh yeah that would
be great I have some at home but as long
as I'm here I don't just spend my time
wrapping a gift for you no but and they
go wow there's one thing are you gonna
they're really this is like you would
think it remember that picture of
everyone in this situation room watching
bin Laden get caught yeah and like by
didn't I mean Hillary's got her hand
over her mouth and Obama's I think you
would think it was that that was the
level of intensity this one's a while
there is a problem though she was like
the helicopters are about to land but
due to the humidity we didn't anticipate
that could crash and the whole mission
would be blown up oh Michael what is it
she's like well then as she's acting
like she can't tell me someone just died
she's like well you know you would have
to refrigerate the cheese right I'm like
yeah if it's in the gift bag well then
then you'd have to put the gift bag the
whole thing in the refrigerator I go
okay that so I was planning to do she
goes but it you could put the cheese in
the gift bag separately but it's just if
I put the cheese in the gift bag now
it's gonna be hard for you to take the
cheese out of the gift bag cuz I'm gonna
do the handles really tight so you
either have to decide right now to let
me give you the gift bag separately and
then give you the cheese separately and
then you can put the cheese in the
refrigerator and then keep the gift bag
out of the refrigerator and then in the
morning take the cheese out and put the
gift bag put it in the gift bag or you
can forget the gift bag and just do it
yourself in the morning or oh no she
can't you didn't say the morning she
goes or you can do it yourself or I can
put the cheese in the gift bag and you
can put it in the refrigerator but the
problem is I'm like this is such a weird
conversation I go what is the problems
because the RHIB you know they curl the
ribbons the ribbons tend to go limp and
in cold air
I go I'm sure they won't I'm giving it
to someone in the morning it's not it's
12 hours about she goes okay but she
bites her tongue like like I'm not ready
to handle the next level of information
she's about to give me she goes well I
just want to let you know that it
doesn't matter how long you have them in
the refrigerator any cold air makes them
go limp I'm like I'm pretty sure in the
history of my life I've walked around
with gift bags in my hands in sub-zero
temperatures with curled ribbons and
they did just fine yeah I've never heard
a thing
she's found talking about her
industrial-sized fridge that's free I go
I'm sure it's fine I go it's for no
offense to your gender I go it's for a
guy yeah I think he's like never seen
but the curled ribbon no and she goes up
and then she goes I just wanted to let
you know Mike I got it this has been so
much mishegoss as Roy Moore's Jewish
lawyer mates say I can't deal
I want to shop local it's too much now
this isn't even the end of the story
Oh No Wow so the curling the ribbon
they're doing the thing they're there
first of all I put in the fridge the
ribbons perfectly curled that's fine
yeah and I didn't want to put the cheese
in the fridge and then the bags separate
because I don't know me in the morning I
walk out with an empty bag yeah so I
give them my Amex card Oh now kiss
anyone Thanks oh you put everything on a
credit card that's what my business
manager told me to do so they can
separate out my things better
I'm not racking up debt but just
sometimes people look at me weird when I
put things on my Amex like you usually
put a trip on an Amex or a big dryer or
something but I put everything on it
yeah and then they separate a ten points
and go for JetBlue points yeah that's
why I'm flying mint all the time
[ __ ] so so the girl behind the
counter different the older woman with
the ribbon she was over there stressing
she's like calling 1-800 line so good to
get advice the younger girl maybe 21 she
goes are you the Jen Kirkman from drunk
history and I think she knew because she
looked at my card and I said yeah I am
now of course my ego
crazy because I've done more than one I
do more than heroic history I go yeah
she goes oh my god my college roommate
and I are obsessed with it or were
obsessed with it we were both history
majors oh my god that's I actually enjoy
this conversation so far is great I
enjoy a compliment I enjoy a compliment
about something I've been part of that I
didn't invent where I don't have to then
explain why did I talk about that
material why it's like I can talk about
Derek I can talk about the concept of
drunk history there so I like talking
about things I was involved with and I'm
proud of because it's it's like I'm not
talking about myself somehow it this
that and she goes I'm sorry I know this
is probably so weird for you and I go no
she goes I mean I'm probably like the
only person who's ever recognized you I
go what and she goes I mean you've
probably never been recognized and
you're just trying to buy cheese and
it's probably like freaking you out I go
oh no I've been recognized before and
she goes from drunk history I'm like
actually yeah quite a bit she goes oh
and I go I mean I'm sort of a and I
can't believe I said this but I was like
I'm just so tired of not shining my own
light I said I'm sort of to some and to
others that no a well-known comedian I
mean a tour on a fan base that comes to
see me
no big numbers on one of the series and
I said I get recognized there she goes
well I mean probably in Los Angeles cuz
people are in entertainment here and
they've probably worked with you before
so now she's like no you only get
recognized in LA by members of the crew
and I go no she's shop employees is she
she look what was she was a hanging on
this fact that she's the only one that's
her I said I don't mean to be weird but
even if that's the only thing I've ever
done
I didn't say this term they rerun that
[ __ ] all the time
so it's like people who've done a
commercial and everyone knows it
because it's Ahnold like it's not that
weird that [ __ ] okay so it's a kind of a
well-known comedian sound like a dick
she goes oh yeah but people in other
places know you yep there's this notion
some people have that
that Los Angeles is where you make your
money doing comedy this literally $20 in
it if you want to do coming they pay you
20 bucks for a spot at the Laugh Factory
The Improv there's literally no money in
it and that's on a bet we're not like Oh
boohoo
it's just we go to practice here and we
live here coz we're selling TV shows
we're doing this we're doing movies you
go on the road but we don't go on it for
our help it's a job that's where the
people pay the money cuz they're none of
the comedian's every 10 minutes like
they do in LA the structure is just set
up differently but every time I tell
people I go on the road they go I'm
sorry as though I'm like I have to leave
home to forth make my fortune which is
true but I always knew that was part of
the deal that was what I wanted to do
the job for so anyway I said well I'm
pretty well known but I get recognized
my fair share obviously I can walk
around the world and most people don't
know who I am but people that like me
are very kind and they come up to me and
they think they'll that we only we have
Netflix who's a we LA probably two great
specials on there oh thank you I don't
think she knew I was a comic okay I said
have things on Netflix
why am i standing here giving her my
resume the least thing I ever want to do
is talk about myself but I felt yeah in
moment of ego and then I just said well
and she was well sorry to freak you out
I still know it's weird Mike it's not
weird yeah
so I'm just like I always the backhanded
compliments about that I that was al is
a labor of love and that cheese she uh
she didn't study complements in history
no I don't I don't and that would be
great the history of compliments like
how it started
no one does them right anyway well thank
you Aaron for being a great inspiration
to me as always and I hope you enjoy
that cheese and I hope you don't get I
hope it's delicious yeah she goes you do
you do you like truffles I go who
doesn't like truffles that likes cheese
because I don't know there's truffles in
there that I go yeah I know it's
controlled yeah what are you trying you
want me to walk out when empty-handed
so by local everybody but local stores
get it together
yeah get it to get don't make people not
want to come in there anymore that's why
I want to do I almost did Amazon now and
some printer paper because that's what I
got for myself this weekend is printer
paper and oh it's the best Amazon now
I've got a bad buy local story Oh tell
me so I I bought a drum set for myself
because I'm a I was a bachelor and I had
the time and the money ah I was gonna
say your wife once but I also lived in
an apartment so I had to buy some mute
pads right and so I went to a local
music store and told them what I needed
and gave them some sizes and they're
like ok and then I called them for three
weeks and I didn't have them and then I
finally went in because they did yeah I
go in the guy is using the phone as I as
I enter it's a small you know small
little place and he's talking about him
he had just been at the airport or
something and then he drops the n-word
jokingly gonna say did someone say
something racist yeah yeah he's singing
on the phone to someone on the phone to
somebody looking at me like right right
and I'm like oh and he's not I mean it's
inappropriate to say at all times but
yeah white man calling someone else in a
bad way oh man alive yeah and what did
you say now then it's not to put you on
yeah I was just like I don't I don't
know what to say
mm-hmm I just came for some drum mutes
it's one of those things to where it's
like and you got them right no because
he didn't I would have paid for them he
hadn't accept debit he had I had I
hadn't cash her a check
so I walked out like okay I'll go get
your check and then I walked out like
I'm not [ __ ] coming back here with a
check I am so proud of you so
technically you did not support him
because of his racism yeah then I had to
go to I went to Amazon found him like
that and if someone's saying the n-word
while they're packaging it you have no
idea I have no idea that's true and
that's what we want we want to be in the
dark more about no that's I love that I
wish I hadn't written a yelp review at
the time I didn't oh we didn't we the
things we didn't know back then yeah now
the pads really help they know that much
no I had to sell it
two years later that's two years of
annoying your name yeah well they were
just dusty at that point oh my god I
just couldn't do it in good conscience
yeah I feel like I would hear someone's
muted drumming no matter well didn't
stop my upstairs
from playing his guitar the same two
songs over and over I'd say you guys get
started a band yeah that's how nothing
but Jason Mraz and Plain White T's
that's how the great started John Lennon
McCartney nuts Lennon Ringo right there
but you guys you know we're in a world
now where we don't talk to our neighbors
and so no good bands get started good
work Aaron you just ruin to music um
weird if I join a band at 30 with like
15 year old but I guess George was young
oh my god that would be really creepy
actually
hmm the inappropriate age gap errs
that's cute I don't think about it
all right folks well what are we gonna
talk about timing there's so much
there's so much okay so this is gonna
dub him so folks folks
my sister's cabman's you know he was on
and she he I admit I'm a I'm a gender
conformist because my sisters count as a
tuxedo cat and I do get confused and
call it a he because men wear tuxedos
more than women although women look
great when they wear them to the red
carpet
well mittens is becoming quite popular
my Instagram and I started an Instagram
account called life with mittens but
it's it's those underscores in between
life with a lot of Instagram accounts
mittens
I mean it's tried 50 things the most
gave up within a couple hours mittens
got like 500 followers pretty good
mittens is more popular than well not me
but no now I'm more popular than me
can't even go to a cheese shop without
getting recognized but just popular now
mittens everybody is a beautiful little
kitty who's innocent she doesn't know
from you creeps on the internet and some
guy who I must have blocked on my
account started an account you know he
had zero followers he was fought he was
only following mittens and he had one
post which was the post that was like
because on mittens account it says eye
mittens I'm a girl cat I live in
Massachusetts at Jen Kirkman runs my
account or at least she thinks she does
fun here so the guy was like
tell at jen kirkman this whole rant at
me about how I'm a snob and I'm this
because I don't like customer service
and when I'm on the road people
shouldn't talk to me and I'm like I was
laying in bed like I gotta get on the
mic and I know you guys listen and get
it but I want to explain what what has
been I did these [ __ ] tour diaries on
my Instagram stories and I was showing
again there's so many comedians out
there who present this [ __ ] life or
they do those photos like I'm on a plane
flying here and it's so obviously a
private jet and they're there they don't
mention it in the photo but there's wood
paneling there's like one seat on the
whole plane it's like we know I've been
on a private jet 50 times no eight times
with Chelsea every time I posted a
picture if about it it would be like
this is insane I'm on a private jet or
something or just at that point in the
collection of photos I was posting I
didn't have to keep mentioning it but it
was obvious I'm a guest of a celebrity
on a private jet and I'm a SMO and you
know whatever and I also don't like
private jets to scare the [ __ ] out of me
I hope I don't have to do it again I
wouldn't voluntarily do it I don't know
I would have to but you never know maybe
I would get a job and they'd be like
sorry you have to fly with the there's a
lot of people that actually I forget if
Chelsea was like this I think she might
have been but I wouldn't I bet she
wouldn't even know she was like this if
that makes sense she'd be like oh I
didn't mean to be but it was sort of
like you're more of a pain in the ass if
you don't fly with her you're like oh
I'll just get myself there it's like
well then forget I'll just ask Chris cuz
he's can just come they just want all
eyes on you everyone in the same place
makes it easier you all check in at the
same time it's just easier and I get
that like you just you're touring you
don't want to have to worry if someone's
going to show up or not so you know my
flight could get delayed to Atlanta hers
is it whatever so there's a lot of times
that I did not want to get on that
private jet but I did it because I was
like otherwise I'm if I live we don't
crash I'm never gonna live down how
annoying and in a weird way I'm more
high maintenance that I won't get on the
private jet because it's what everyone
else is doing so blah-dee-blah
so these comedians they do stuff like
that now I know
I just mentioned Chelsea as a private
jet she's blatantly does a bit in her
act like I flew my dogs private I'm rich
so she's not trying to be false modesty
so I'm not talking about Chelsea and if
I were to be find you but I'm just
saying I thought it would be funny and
an all-encompassing funny of like this
is me showing you the most boring parts
of tour the parts that proved to you I
cannot go have coffee with you I have to
do this or that now I was just listening
to Jerry Seinfeld on Howard Stern and
boy he seems he sounds a little out of
touch lately like I'm not trying to be
one of these like over PC people that's
like we always have to say he she they
them and we can't ever just use him as a
as a you know I don't mean when you're
actually talking about a real person but
if I was like you know like a
construction guy comes over like oh I
said guy is that the norm you know I
could say construction person like I'm
not trying to be like that but whenever
he talks about comedies like the guys
that do this the guys that he's oh says
guys guys guys guys guys
he's very male but I always love Jerry
and I love his insights but like lately
I'm like oh he's tipping he's just
tipping everyone tips into the
generation that they were born into
eventually when you get older you're
gonna fight it you gonna fight it so
he's tipping into just like he sounds
very male I don't Hawks fighting anyway
but Jerry wouldn't let and not in a rude
way like get away from you peasant but
you know the the people at the show
Howard show they help you put your
headphones on ER they know they were
putting on the lavalier mic and he's
like I got it and her it's like what is
that about and Jerry's like I I got it I
can put on my own mic I just suddenly
got this fussing muscling around me and
it comes off very like comedian very
like East Coast Jewish guy like to put
all the stereotypes together of like uh
with the fussing I totally relate I'm
totally like that Larry David same thing
the whole point of Seinfeld and curb is
like no hugging no learning they said it
it's literally the most popular show of
all time this curb is up there too for
something that is on HBO which again
like not a lot of the country has
comparatively to NBC it's still wildly
popular among all kinds of people it's
not a nice show like transparent or
girls it's like huge okay so their whole
era is like complain
like I can't why is the parking ticket
over there why are you so what are you
doing Larry David does a whole bit about
small talk I want Big Talk
it's and we love them in their hilarious
now maybe I'm not being as hilarious as
them I'm not trying to be I'm on a I'm
on an Instagram story which is not
punched up written perfected through my
persona it's just me being me going I'm
not really this upset in my heart about
it but my mind is going on either so
annoying and I'm doing that kind of
attitude it's like that kind of thing
and I'm giving uh-oh what's with this
kind of thing you know and so I'm doing
that so on my Instagram stories I talked
about how again with the cheese shop
that person knew who I was and it ends
up insulting when people don't know who
you are and you tell them you're a comic
they don't mean to but the questions are
so insulting you are well what are you
doing in town I'm at the theatre how do
people know about you well I just am a
comic with it are you funny
what's your material and it's like dude
I'm trying to check into a hotel and
you're like phones ringing and other
things are happening like so I was on
tour this year while writing a pilot
while promoting a jewelry line while
doing press for the next city that I was
doing while handling all the merch like
I'm doing 50 things at once and so I was
talking about traveling alone as a woman
which by the way is also scary I got
into a few lifts where the guy was like
you smell nice and I was like okay bye
and I want to talk about it maybe like I
smelled you since before you got in the
car Mike okay stop talking like it was
really scary
okay so that being said I was talking
about on my tour diaries and I would
show you imagine this and this is what I
mean people have lost and some young
people never had and I'm sorry to say
young people but you can't tell me what
I don't notice I see hundreds of people
a week when I'm on the road for years I
noticed things and generations older
people this younger people that my
generation this it's a thing those
generations as personality traits based
on it not a hundred percent but I notice
what the younger kids and maybe it's
something they'll grow out of maybe it's
because they're millennial I don't know
what I'm saying there seems to be this
lack of empathy where it's like less how
do I attack that person how do I take it
personally instead of like oh I see what
they're doing they're just sort of
giving a day-in-the-life but they're
leaning into the annoying parts for
comedy okay
the concept is comedy whether or not
every line I say is funny so this guy
writes she thinks you're too good for
her don't look her in the eye no that's
very different than saying I don't want
small talk and a lift so many times when
I was on the road I'm working with like
the ABC network and Universal Studios is
a small time bits okay I can't tell them
no I can't get on a conference call I'm
on the road they know that I have a few
hours free so I would say okay the plane
lands at 3:00 and I check into the hotel
at 4:00 but once I check into the hotel
you know then I have to get to the venue
and shower so maybe the good time to
talk would be from 3:00 to 4:00 when I'm
in the car you know on the way to there
from the airport to the hotel I would
find a cab or a lift it Marvin the not a
man and they always just look at me
through the rearview mirror like just
listening to what I'm doing excuse me
now is it a gender thing who [ __ ] it
whatever it is is annoying I get in the
car hello hey Jen here in the notes and
I'm like okay and I'm literally on my
laptop in the backseat typing I'm like
okay so Joe the character Joe he
shouldn't [ __ ] his pants no we think he
should throw up okay that's good and
they're like where are you from
what where are you visiting why are you
here I'm like I'm on the phone so sorry
I'm on the phone like ha what and so I
so imagine this this is how many times a
day I had to deal with the same question
of where are you from why are you
visiting and what do you do for a living
this is how many times in the car on the
way to the airport from my house
possibly person next to me on the plane
in the car from the airport to the hotel
checking into the hotel
if I get room service the person coming
into my room now asking me that the car
cab lift from the hotel to the venue the
car cab lift home from the venue to the
hotel checking out of the hotel getting
in a cab car lift to the airport that's
9 times in less than 24 hours now four
days of that in a row that's 36 times
don't tell me that you wouldn't lose
your damn mind if you had one of these
weird jobs where you can do it but
you're not famous but you people know
you and people are fat
with it and they want to talk about it
you're like I know you're fascinated but
I literally only get asked this every 10
minutes and sometimes I just want to be
quiet
this woman picked me up at 4:30 in the
morning once and you could tell she had
kids because their juice boxes in the
car she was a lyft driver the child
seats probably up at all crazy hours and
used to it and she was just like so how
was your visit and I was asleep in the
back of my covers all right I've had two
hours sleep and I couldn't skimp on
sleep cuz the minute my plane landed in
LA I had to go meet with my producer so
I was like please please people it was
from that point of view not like I won't
talk to the underclass
I am underclass you [ __ ] so it's just
like what don't you get about that and I
think it's sexism I think guys some guys
young guys they get upset when a woman
because they don't see you as a comedian
they see was a woman is bitching
bitching bitching in the vein of a Jerry
Seinfeld or Larry David like oh I can't
believe it would just shut up what am I
going to talk to you for I'm getting a
salad so we gonna sell it that gets that
kind of thing you know and my whole
point is that these people they know
like when a woman is saying it because
they take it personally as a man because
we've seen some men really cute I can't
hug you at the Christmas party no cuz of
all this don't be a [ __ ] to say a
sexist word I've seen some of my friends
online being low deuces really going too
far maybe it is so let the pendulum
swing to the craziest side of all and
then we'll come back and get in the
middle again when when everyone is ready
to handle a conversation about what's
harassment what isn't what is you know I
think we're not ready to have that
conversation I think some people are
taking it too far some some my liberal
people are getting a little too crazy
I'm not saying that being touched on the
waist isn't unpleasant if you didn't
want it but it there's there's
variations and I'm not saying those guys
are okay those guys aren't I'm saying
let's have a conversation so cuz some
people that may only be touching your
waist and thinking it's funny
they're probably educated able to be
educated and then they can probably go
oh [ __ ] oh my god I didn't my male
priviledge my this I'm older above OB we
can talk to them about it and actually
they can be on our side they could join
our team instead of ostracizing them and
then they're like now I don't even know
what the [ __ ] to do because no one's had
a conversation with me gotta have the
conversation and then people raping you
know children well
we don't talk to them we just put them
in jail so that's the scale and everyone
stop being such a [ __ ] little [ __ ]
drama queen about everything men I'm
talking to your with it again you can do
this and don't do it don't touch anyone
ever again and then it'll balance out
just stop making it about you
anyway so I think guys watch my thing
and they go oh I've talked to people in
a car before yeah you're embarrassed
because you're thinking of all the times
you probably invaded someone's privacy
but I think and it's not a guy thing
it's an everyone thing I like to talk to
strangers when I am traveling the world
when I am alone in Australia sitting in
a bar I made some of my best friends and
I'm so is that I'm not going to
Australia again it just it's never gonna
work out again because I what was my
favorite wine bar there punch Lane
here's the thing with Australia it
worked out really well when I worked at
Chelsea Lately because the week off we
had in March was the week that I was
able to go the festival then when I was
freelancing I mean just doing stand-up I
could decide my tours in advance and I
could take a month off but now that I'm
working in TV again it's like jobs
happen during that time or I have to be
auditioning or I have to be taking
meetings so it's during the worst time
of year for Americans I could go for a
week maybe if they'd let me I just don't
have a new show like I I was going there
so much and doing all the hours that I
ended up doing here that I could do new
stuff there now actually I do actually I
could go this year if they would let me
but I'm waiting to see if I'm getting
this job in New York I'm waiting to see
this I'm waiting to see that so and
unfortunately because they don't have a
comedy scene really in Australia they
have the big festival Melbourne I can't
just go on my own other times of the
year sort of it there's sort of a
lockdown I don't want to get into the
politics of it but the people that run
the festival like they don't it's it's
sort of like they do that once a year
and the the venue's aren't that amenable
to other people coming in and doing
comedy outside of the festival so you
can't really get it's hard to explain
I'm sure I can work around it mm-hm but
then at that point we're talking about
my own dime to Australia when I do the
festival I get paid and I get a free
apartment and I get a first-class ticket
so and I get all the press like massive
amounts of press that they do I don't
have to hire a publicist so
I actually get to profit if I go to
Australia by myself for shows I probably
won't lose $5,000 so it's just how it is
it sucks I want to go back it's like I
miss it so [ __ ] much anyway so I
think everybody needs to chill the [ __ ]
out shut up so it's if one more person
asked me to read an article about
harassment in comedy just shut the [ __ ]
up we said what we said this harassment
and there isn't there's harassment
everywhere so this course is in comedy
it's not out it's not interesting it's
not interesting to me I don't want to
read an article for your [ __ ] women's
magazine I'll talk about on the podcast
when I feel like talking about it okay
thank you anyway I'm just saying and I
also think and now I don't know where
I'm getting this thought but I went to
my breast doctor last week now she's a
specialist who talks to me about all
things boobs she says you have a high
risk because your sister had breast
cancer you have had lumpectomies that
are benign you have dense breasts you
have high risks so you need to tell me
what you've been doing about it my go I
get a mammogram every year an MRI every
five every five no just get a good
mammogram and then six months later
gonna MRI and that's how you do it every
year because we've we need to catch it
early if we're gonna catch it and then
you need to get that bracha gene test
I'm like no problem so we're chatting
and they have to ask you a million
things did your dad ever have cancer
what how old's your mom's turtle you
know like things you don't think are
related and she goes are you Ashkenazi
Jewish I go no and she goes what kind of
Jewish I go I'm a Jewish she goes sure I
go yeah now I don't she just probably
asked everybody that I know if there's
some kind of breast cancer with the
Ashkenazi whatevs
there must be because then another woman
came and asked me that I'm like what is
this question so I don't think they were
like you seem Jewish whatever that is
then I know you know the guy that was
like what does seem gay mean he's
yelling at me I don't mean seemed you
know but I was I thought it was funny in
a way that then she brought it up later
and was like you're really not Jewish
and I was like no and she goes oh just
she goes up and I think she might have
been her
I'm not sure my name Kirkman I'm
peopling a Jewish but the Kirk part to
me is so waspy the man is Jewish
sounding but I actually looked up my
family's history I'll tell you all about
it um but I'm not Jewish but what was
interesting it just got me thinking is I
am ever appropriated Jewish culture I'm
Jewish at heart and I don't mean that so
offensive because I cuz Comedy is Jewish
I grew up watching Joan Rivers Lenny
Bruce these people been in my head my
whole life their cadence the rhythm
Howard Stern not that there's a Jewish
thing but they're kind of there is
culturally and they would say it but you
know who would get mad about it
white wasps in their first year of woke
nests who are gonna email me make it
seem Jewish mean I'll forward it to
Jewish friends they'll be like oh my god
get a life
all my friends in comedy New York New
York is Jewish New York is New York but
New York is also very Irish but New York
is is in New York you know so I've got
in my blood in my nature or nurture
I was natured Catholic and then through
comedy and then through living in New
York and through consistently more
comedy more New York I'm nurtured in New
York I pronounce things a certain way
too so I feel like there's this lack of
connection with the Jewishness of comedy
that young people don't get there's
there's a there's a big generation thing
that's missing a jump that they don't
kind of understand the dark humor the
even the Irish gallows humor they don't
get everything is OH or or why are you
complaining it's like it's not
complaining it's a way of communication
it's actually way of celebrating it's
it's people I call it on the surface and
then deep down there's a gratitude and a
service to God and of this it's up top
or just knit nitpicking and it did to
pop up on and I just don't think the
kids get that I think they don't get
that and I don't know what and I swear
to you and I've said this before I saw
it happen and I'm not blaming him cuz
it's like cool to blame him or I have an
opinion on him it's it's just the kind
of comedy he put out in the world and
again I'm about to if the sitcom gets
picked up put out a real sugary pop
thing during you know the end of the
world so people be like why is that what
she wanted to say because I've been
wanting to say it for 20 years and I
just got the chance I'm not gonna read
Jigar my whole sitcom idea
because trump president anyway but the
Dane Cook positive waspy comedy I'm
telling you it trained a whole new
generation of people to be like I'm a
winner I did it this situation I did
something cool I mean my tank top
there's no shame or self thing or it's
okay I'm telling you I wish someone
could do an essay on it somebody out
there smarter than me put that in your
sociology class we're losing we're
losing the New York Jewishness out there
in the world hmm
and when Howard Stern goes off the air
I'm gonna die die anyway are we at the
ads time is it 30 minutes folks I now I
can't sing along to Santa Clauses come
into town right all right now quip oh my
god I just signed up and not kidding you
know I only advertise things I believe
in I actually do the equip subscription
service
what is quip well I'm gonna tell you
what it is if you guys are just caught
just calm the [ __ ] [ __ ] down for a
minute people and quip did ask they said
specifically tell everyone that might
buy our product calm the [ __ ] down all
right folks
here's something to chew on many recent
studies suggest that having good oral
health impacts our overall health that
it's true there is a connection to heart
disease and bad teeth health but most of
us don't brush our teeth properly and we
know that because our hygienists always
tell us that and make us feel bad and
then we're like we're totally gonna do
it this time so she'll never say that to
me again and then we get lazy so here is
how I and quip can help you you don't
need a big expensive toothbrush to get
the oral care you need you can get the
same refreshing clean with something
simpler that'll give you the best
brushing experience you've ever had okay
you don't have to dish out hundreds for
a top-of-the-line electric toothbrush
this is true I had one of those and it
was so heavy I loved quit in it and it
does this thing where it vibrates and
then turns off vibrates and turns off so
you know when to switch which quadrant
of your teeth you're doing I love it so
we are introducing quip the new company
that's refreshing the way people brush
their teeth it's an electric toothbrush
that packs premium vibration and timer
features into an ultra slim does
it is it's ultra slim and I have a rose
gold one and it looks so pretty in my
bathroom and then they give you this
really cool case and you can stick it on
your mirror and it just looks modern and
sleek and just like just like you have
your life together
like if someone goes into your bathroom
and sees equipped toothbrush instead of
just one of those old like janky ones
plastic ones you get the they're like
this person has this person is style has
class it's basically like if Apple
designed a toothbrush okay and this is
my favorite part they are in with the
modern times because you can subscribe
to receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three-month plan for just
five bucks that's free shipping as well
so just comes to you you don't have to
think about it it's backed by leading
dentists and was named as one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of 2016 and
they are on oprah's 2017 new years o
list it starts at just $25 but if you go
to get quip comm slash fun you will get
your first refill pack free with equip
electric toothbrush that is get quip
comm GE tqu IP comm slash fun again I do
use this and look how pretty my what you
can't see them over the radio but the
radio gather around
I'm beautiful too you get quick calm GE
tqu IP comm slash fun sorry folks folks
folks folks what are you doing you
arguing with your families I told you
what did I tell you back in August
get your therapy together so that you
can survive the holiday season you're
like well it's too late all the
therapists are on vacation I I know Jen
I didn't listen to you
well that's why we love the internet
take advantage of it talks face the
online therapy company you've got a week
people before you sit down that
Christmas dinner and everyone starts
talking about politics or whatever ain't
move whatever politics gonna try to say
and you're gonna start your arguments
with you always that's on how you that
is not how you communicate with people
unless you want them to flip out so you
can learn tools things like this I mean
and then after the holidays you stay
with your therapist and you go deeper
and you learn about yourself
I got to tell you this whole year
because of therapy I mean I've always
been in it but thank God but my life
changed okay talk space so you can do it
online no one will know you're doing it
it's extremely private and confidential
like I mean obviously all therapy is but
you don't have to drive there you don't
have to tell people what you're doing
just sneak away into your room then your
little single bed that you're still
sleeping in your old childhood bedroom
you can get on you get on your parents
dial up I'm just kidding and you get on
talk space okay
talk space the online therapy company
for as little as thirty two dollars a
week that's an absurdly low price for
therapy
you can pick an experienced licensed
therapist that you relate to and feel
comfortable with each and every
therapist has at least a master's degree
and has completed over 3,000 hours of
supervised work at least a master's is
HUGE HUGE to come to match with your
perfect therapist go to talk space.com
slash Jen chieh en and to show your
support for this podcast when you check
out use code Jen and get $30 off of your
first month that's Jen and just go to
talk space.com slash gin they're not
gonna suck you into the computer make
you buy anything just read read about it
more talk space.com slash Jen therapy
for how we live today again you can text
audio and video message or even do a
live video chat with your therapist that
is revolutionizing the way that we do
therapy and lastly Rent the Runway oh my
god if you want to be like me and I've
been using Rent the Runway for years so
I was so excited when they wanted to
sponsor on this podcast people is gonna
wear you to get your clothes this is
where I get them okay I don't want a
closet full of clothes but nothing to
wear you know what I'm saying I want to
express myself with what I wear but I I
don't want to have to keep buying new
things all the time and and yeah in my
closet the things I have it's like a
boring black dress or like the same coat
of one a million times but fashion
freedom is Rent the Runway and what I
love about it is when it's on it's like
the old Netflix system you know with the
with the with the DVDs when you rent an
outfit from Rent the Runway if you're on
the unlimited subscription you literally
can keep it until the world ends I mean
eventually if you if you and then you
you don't get you know what I'm saying
like you have three items you
keep them I'm not explaining it well but
you can keep your rental for as long as
you want it means you have less rentals
more to choose from but it's not like
get it back in a week
you can kind of live with it and then
send it back when you're sick of it
which I love because you know you wear
things a few times and then you're like
okay and it goes in your closet you
never wear it again with red thrown away
it goes right back and you get new stuff
so I use it all the time most of my TV
appearances is a Rent the Runway outfit
when I am I'm not wearing one today
unfortunately when I am on the road rent
the one runt the runway shirts I will in
pictures I will I will let you guys know
on the ice ceem fun on the facebook.com
slash I see a fun podcast page I'll put
up my rent the runway photos for you
guys okay so introducing rent the
runways unlimited membership that's the
one I have unlimited access to a
constantly I mean guys there's so much
in there I have like a like list of like
hundreds constantly rotating dream
closet full of designer styles that you
can keep as long as you want and swap
anytime you can rent from over 450 top
designer brands like Vince theory Tory
Burch Derek Lam Opening Ceremony Marni
DVF and more Marchesa got the gowns you
can rent gowns and beautiful and you
girls are in a sweater it's like it's
got everything purse jewelry everything
renting is not only cheaper than buying
it's faster and easier to there is free
shipping and free dry cleaning on every
piece you don't have to send it back dry
cleaned go to Rent the Runway comm or
download the app to choose from tops
dresses handbags and many more for any
occasion and I'm serious they send you
the return slip so you just put it in
the thing and you send it back it's like
you don't have to do anything you just
drop it you just drop it somewhere I
mean you don't just drop it in the road
I mean you drop it at your UPS place
seventy percent of unlimited members
actually spend less money on clothes
after joining so join the six million
members who make rent the runway the
largest clothing rental company in the
world so go to Rent the Runway dot-com
or download the app I have both to get
25% off your first month's unlimited
membership with promo code fun at
checkout that's Rent the Runway comm 25%
at most of 25 cents 25 cents off 25% off
your first month's membership promo code
fun Rent the Runway
promo code fun it takes the thinking on
a getting dressed because you always
have something to wear you can select
for pieces at a time keep them as long
as you want and when you're ready for
something new swap any of your pieces
for fresh styles if you fall in love
with a style you can actually buy it and
at an exclusive discount price and keep
it forever I've done that
alright folks and I'll be wearing Rent
the Runway stuff at Christmas time this
year so I'll take photos alright back to
the podcast
ok can do I got 15 here folks
I don't know what it is okay so I'm
thinking about what's going on with this
you know I'm only talking about this
because it seems like things are heating
up but I've been not talking about the
Trump rush of stuff because it just too
much I can't articulate you know Twitter
is kind of where I do that but I'm
saying something here because everyone's
like Donald Trump might fire robert
muller by December 22nd now he says he
isn't but of course whenever he does you
know we're like friends under him you're
gonna fire this verse he's like no no
nobody fires in the next day but what
people need to understand is you don't
he doesn't just go you're fired it's not
the apprentice he has to ask Attorney
General rod Rosenstein to fire Muller
that's that's what was happening in
Nixon when they say the Saturday night
Massacre Nixon was going person to
person I mean I'm oversimplifying making
it cartoonish but going office to office
will you fire this this special
prosecutor no will you fire no going
down the line and then everyone was like
but what what America has been nervous
about is like well what if some of the
people do fire Muller because Trump
asked them to and rod Rosenstein has
made it very clear I ain't doing that
even though rod Rosenstein is a
Republican and I think at one point
might have even been a trump supporter
but I think he understands treason in
the rule of law so they're saying well
he could fire Rosenstein and then Muller
gets fired and then I mean someone took
it done a crazy scenario like the worst
thing Trump could do it but it is legal
or possible is declare like a martial
law and like have people take Muller
no look I don't know what's gonna happen
I do know this Comey knew he'd probably
be fired he had Muller waiting in the
ring rings wings in in the Rings he was
at boxing he was boxing as well I think
Muller is five times better than combing
this guy is a he's a [ __ ] genius it
seems he seems to be going after this
with a precision I don't know what about
comb I know I don't know but maybe just
the case was heating up and so it seems
like anyone after Comey was it was
better but it seems like Muller is
Mark's senior experience whatever it is
that guy has had in place since day one
what if he gets fired if he fires Muller
they unseal all the indictments which
means you get to hear what people are
getting I almost want that happen it
will beam there might be mayhem
everyone's like take to the streets now
they're like take to the streets hold
them accountable I'm like what if they
don't care the streets these are people
in wheelchairs it's like someone with no
limbs it's just a head is screaming at
Congress don't take my health insurance
and like whatevs nobody they don't care
they're all a lot of the GOP are in on
it and they don't care so I'm not saying
don't take the streets but I'm just like
this notion that we're gonna shut down
the economy no no oh who does you know I
don't know we've never been here before
right we've never been here before but
there's something to me so I'm gonna be
in New York City the week of Christmas a
few days before a few days after if
anything happens and I'm in New York
just just you know like what a
three-quarters of a mile away from Trump
Tower like I like to be in the drama and
the excitement as you know I tell I
don't want another 9/11 9/11 reference
but you know I just so excited about
like I know anything bad to happen but
like if he resigns or something happens
just to be in New York with it with the
energy and the people instead of here in
LA everyone's by their pool I just get
out and go to the ice-skating rink at
Bryant Park and just Christmas music
there's something so Dickensian about it
like that that down the street from
Trump is like all the beautiful stores
dressed for Christmas and and the ice
skating and all this it's just like
weird you oh you mr. Potter you like I'm
just I'm crying thinking about tearing
up tearing up I there's something I have
such positivity I
we believe in my heart because I am and
just a hippie dip dip as much as I
wanted Hilary Irwin as much as I did
this [ __ ] has been in the works for
decades this has turned out to be a
global financial conspiracy that also
Hollywood is tied up in Hilary being
president would not have brought it to
light it may not have stopped it it may
have just been a thing where they they
try to [ __ ] with her for eight years or
four years and then it got even it would
get even worse we are exposing
everything I honestly think in the
darkest hour before the dawn in the true
way that the blessing of him being
elected and I'm not saying as Susan
Sarandon we needed revolution way that
be very clear here I'm saying it would
have been better if Hillary was elected
and we still would have been looking at
this stuff they always would have been
investigating Trump they had been since
before the election but what I'm saying
is for you ding-dongs who don't read the
news now it's on your face you get to
see what's happening now of course you
know I people my family that still think
Trump is great Muller's bad I read them
the things he said he's a nays of Purple
Heart he's a great man you know and I
have all these concern my whole life now
is on Twitter hanging out with
conservatives on Mike hey Richard
painter Bill Kristol I mean people I
don't normally agree with that well Bill
Kristol still annoying but Richard
painters a genius but talking about
being a patriot being this is America
we're not [ __ ] Russia that the man is
a dictator who kills people this is
horrible but these people don't want
America these people that love Trump
it's not like oh we have to convince
them that they're democracies they want
democracy being taken over they don't
want things to be fair I can
specifically look at the personality
types of my family that like Trump they
never got rich they're mad they like the
big powerful rich guy in the last year
through of their life they can feel like
[ __ ] you I don't want it to be fair when
I'm gone for some reason it's gonna
bother me that black people can make
money it's gonna bother me none bother
me my grave
it's ignorant it's willful ignorance
there isn't Trump himself could tell
them not to believe in him and they
would not stop so and everyone get off
your ass thinking that this is going to
change anyone's
now listen to me there's something about
this time of year lightness in a time of
dark I am I am moved by thinking about
how this Christmas like we're kind of
all in this together and there's
something telling me that this
investigation is gonna heat up this week
like I have this weird feeling he might
be out before New Year's now I've always
said that and I'm probably wrong but I
there's something I don't know I'm just
getting I'm getting a feeling of a
thrill but that's also one of my big
problems and I learned it this year is
like addicted to excitement as they call
it and so it's not a very good thing I'm
when I'm when I used to travel all the
time you know six months six countries a
year it's like I was running from myself
and so this year I was very grounded and
it actually I'd never been healthier so
I will end this with them I I was in
touch with my ex who raghav me at
Christmas because I thought well the the
the blessing and be in touch with him
was like now I won't be wondering what
his life wasn't and I won't be on
Christmas like couple glass of wine like
I don't miss him I don't were just with
them but there's obviously a ton of
history there he's one of my favorite
people but then I had to realign like
well stop saying someone's your favorite
person if you haven't been in their life
for a year like you have other people
now and I didn't date for a year and I'm
still not I'm gonna continue that like I
really don't it's not a thing I'm
interested in like if I met someone of
course I guess but it I feel like people
can feel it emanating off of me -
because I'm not getting any weird
getting hit on on Twitter this year it's
pretty amazing when you just plant your
flag in the ground with confidence and
no self shame where you're just like
yeah that's not the thing I'm doing
right now like nobody bothers you about
it's been an amazing year but I talked
to my ex Annette and and many of you if
you know who he is I don't want to say
too much about him because I don't want
to tell his story but he was very kind
and he knows he handled things badly
it's not I regret we should be together
thing it's a more he's like I had [ __ ]
to work on basically he and I shouldn't
have gotten back together when we did we
both had stuff to work on in our lives
and we thought well we'll just do that
and be together and it just that doesn't
always work and so he and it kind of
made things implode we we we are so
similar and yet so different and so when
we have things in our you know like
solicit to use a crazy big words like
trauma and existing from our past when
that stuff comes up each of us handles
it differently but it doesn't go well
with how the other one handles stuff so
not big fiery fights or anything like
that just sort of like a lot of like
he's an isolator and he'll go inward or
not tell me anything and I'll be like
wow and think everything's fine and and
then I noticed that like we kind of were
emotionally enmeshed and I didn't think
you could be if you were like I'm
traveling the world how come I'm in mesh
with another person like we were each
other's everything in this weird way and
it was like you know and and and we were
just I was oh my god were those people
were those people that like don't see
their friends and we're just like
together all the time and it's like our
own little university crates gross it's
gross it's gross it's like a you too
much candy you feel sick it's just not
but the some people are like that we
like kind of can't help but whenever
we're together so you know mm-hmm it's
good taken apart but he said he had a
terrible year nothing went well and I
had to laugh because I the most amazing
year and every one of my dreams came
true
so it's not a revenge thing it's that
what it was very humbling what it taught
me was I am never in like I cannot sit
there and have negative fantasy about
how my life is gonna go I'm so humbled
by the things a Power greater than my
self out there in the world lined up for
me or nothing lined up for me just
that's just the cycle of life and I
couldn't have controlled you know what
I'm saying even control things within
reason like you can apply for a job or
whatever but I was just humbled by what
a beautiful year I had I felt shitty the
entire time until I healed and then I
look back and went holy [ __ ] there was
not one week that something beautiful
wasn't going on whether it was a new job
or new friends or connecting with old
friends or just moments where just life
was so beautiful and also all this Trump
stuff was so horrible but it brought me
closer to people in talking about it so
anyway I finally watched that Jimmy
Fallon
but molars coming to town thing and
everyone's tell me about it but you know
how regular a regular folks are I'm like
yeah yeah yeah but it's funny I get
annoyed with Jimmy Fallon because it's
like dude you rub the guy's hair and
made him look like a kewpie doll like or
you know like and then he's like I don't
talk about politics like all right but
you know in Jimmy's way we know he's a
patriot against Trump but but it just in
his own way that's how he had to do it
was that song I wish he'd do jokes every
night about it and not have him on and
be like whatever I do that both sides
know but I had to admit this I'm part of
the song that may mean laughs and then
the rest was like yeah I could see that
coming the part of the song and really
it's just an excuse for him to wear
sleeveless shirt and sing the part that
I thought was so funny that is straight
from Bruce Springsteen Santa Claus
coming to him this part when Bruce does
this to the audience
hang on and he goes yeah yeah yeah and
he asks everyone if they've been good
right
[Music]
all right not that my mom hates the Sun
he's faking and working-class accent my
friend Steve said no he was like broke
Juanita this is late seventies he wasn't
famous yet my god that's critical
he already sounds like a star all right
oh this part sorry I'm talked right over
it he asked the audience he asked the
audience if they'd been good I'm already
ruining oh god I'm making this not funny
[Music]
so the detailed that Jimmy founded
because everyone in the tribe
administration been good or what not
many not many I cracked up laughing it's
just details cuz you go oh if you didn't
know that was part of the song they're
gonna be nothing funny about it now I'm
not a Bruce Springsteen fan don't get
mad at me yes I know he's a show on
Broadway he's a great guy working-class
hero but it just the music doesn't
squeeze Elvis Costello and Bruce
Springsteen not saying they're the same
thing
but I literally I live in a shame where
I cannot tell people I just don't like
the music it doesn't do a thing for me I
can't I'm trying it's like I don't like
coconut I'm not attracted to the rock
these things will never change I can't I
can't I'm not trying to convince anyone
else I don't want to get letters okay
look at that technical note structure I
don't care and then I did but the one
song I love is for Springsteen Santa
Claus is coming to town and I was
telling Erin it makes me cry I don't
know why there's like a joy inside of it
but I'm just picturing myself in New
York this year after my hard year going
I'm the luckiest girl in the world I'm
gonna be there with best friends of mine
in a beautiful hotel that I can afford
evil Trump is down the street and we're
all gonna march against him if we have
to and he's so dumb he did treason so
badly it all came down to emails
the irony is like ah it just makes even
if we lose we know we're right we know
we're right light in a time of dark oh
my god it makes me so happy the song I
don't know why I get in touch with an
inner joy oh my god well let me close on
this drive time to read something really
quick because next week's Christmas
episode is the hallmark movie episode
that I recorded a month ago and it's
boring so this is really your Christmas
episode I wrote this for the Guardian UK
it's going to come out soon but they're
going to shorten it so I'm gonna give it
to you guys and this is the one year
this is the the story I didn't tell you
guys about until August and now we're at
the end and this
is it so Merry Christmas everybody
that's sorry but say Merry Christmas on
December 28th of 26 called reclaiming
Christmas on December 28th of 2016 I got
dumped in my home in Los Angeles right
next to my Christmas tree to be fair my
ex-boyfriend didn't quite bring it up I
sensed it there wasn't a big fight in
fact we spent Christmas day alone
sitting on my couch watching the box set
of Maude a gift from him
we were really compatible looking back
at the selfie I took of us on my couch
in pajamas his face looks worried like
he's trapped behind glass I now realized
his feelings were trapped inside of his
guilt when I asked him if he was having
doubts he admitted it he didn't quite
dump me as much as he honestly answered
a question that I asked of him which was
are you thinking of dumping me but you
don't want to be the guy who dumps his
girlfriend during Christmas take it from
me ladies or men if the answer is yes
there's no working on that it's time for
acceptance of course I went through the
five stages of grief in about five
seconds a sixth stage was invented where
I judged him for keeping the attach and
David Bowie coffee table book that I
bought him I felt he should have left it
with me the dumpee is a consolation
prize Christmas is my favorite time of
year we met and fell in love instantly
red flag yes but a fun one in New York
City during Christmas of 2011 every year
I'd begin putting up my Christmas
decorations in October something that
reminds me that I can have hope and
lightness in the dark is the ridiculous
ritual of putting a tree in my living
room and putting up twinkly lights
during the darkest months of the year so
to be dumped on my favorite holiday the
holiday that reminds me I can have hope
was like the Grinch stealing my hope
snuffing out my candle flame and did I
mention keeping the David Bowie coffee
table book we have spoken recently we
both get what happened and how actually
now we're grateful for the breakup but
how did I get from there to here
oh by the way I said to him I can't be
in touch anymore because the holidays
have to be about me I mean I'm sure
someday we'll be friends again but no
time soon I'm going to list some of the
things I did and it's going to read the
same way an article about dieting reads
yeah I know eat six almonds for a snack
and drink lots of water but here goes I
continued working on myself at therapy
took meditation classes went to support
groups read books on grief leaned on my
friends and slept but the two most
important things I did were no dating or
sex or anything like that for one year
I'm still doing this to drop my story I
did not cover up my feelings rebounding
with another person I'm truly in a
relationship with myself people praise
those who continually work on a
relationship but if you say you're
working on the relationship with
yourself and invite scoffs and people
incur
- stop doing that get back out there I'm
more out there than I've ever been
I'm just not dating there's turned out
to be the best year of my life because
my entire life plan had been blown up I
said yes to new things like a job that
required me to move for a while it's
interesting how we do that we insist
what we want the rest of our lives to
look like but what if sometimes we
aren't dreaming big enough or just right
enough I spent the first few months just
handling my shame I thought that if a
longtime partner dumps me I say a
longtime we were separated for a little
while but we overall we've been together
like four years I thought that if a
longtime partner dumps me it must mean I
failed
I saw myself through the eyes of society
a dumped woman must be a problem woman I
realized my self-esteem sucked even
though I get up on stage and make people
laugh and I'm really confident deep down
I think I saw myself as damaged goods I
truly do not think that way anymore
I really within reason don't give a [ __ ]
about what people think of me let's say
that someone does think I'm a failure
that's their business the voice in my
head that told me I'm not lovable until
I'm loved romantically and that the love
of friends and family is second rate
nope that voice is now homeless so
dropping a story when something bad
happens if our self-esteem is crap we
pile on ourselves we tell ourselves
horrible stories I told myself stories
about my ex he's happy he's dating a 21
year old model he's the recipient of one
of those scam emails from a Nigerian
prince but he's literally the first
person ever who actually responded and
received millions of dollars most of my
pain was negative fantasy
I dropped the story that he was the love
of my life and I'll never meet anyone
else and everyone else gets to be you
the loves of their lives just not me
see it's exhausting just hearing that
right the real story is simple a person
broke up with me on December 28th 2016
that's it the future was not written in
stone that minute I had to learn to take
life not just one day at a time but one
minute at a time I had to realize that I
don't know is that the best ideas about
how my life should turn out I had to
start changing my brain chemistry and a
quote from Rumi became my mantra live as
if the world is tipped in your favor
back in January of last year I was
already planning Christmas 2017 my plan
was to draw the shades and stay inside
no decorations no parties no velvet
outfits people would pity me and say she
really loved Christmas and now it's
forever ruined in an odd way I felt I
would be judged if I tried to enjoy
myself and I would be romanticized and
respected if I stayed in pain
like a woman who can't get over her
husband who went missing in World War
one a friend of mine gave me great
advice he said you have no idea how
you'll feel in 11 months don't plan for
pain he reminded me that I had given him
the same advice once well yeah it's true
for other people like him but not me I
knew I was never gonna feel better and
then one day in September I found myself
on Pinterest looking at DIY Christmas
decoration ideas I started to catch the
spirit and have epiphanies I have had
decades of Christmases before I knew my
ex even existed did I ever feel like
something was missing no and this is my
holiday somehow because we met at
Christmas I turned that into our story
we met at Christmas in New York when he
lived there and I didn't because I was
on my yearly solo trip in December to
see friends enjoy the snow the lights it
was because of my solo adventures and my
love of Christmas that I had found love
that time with a little perspective I
realized that the love story here is
between Christmas and me I plan to avoid
New York City this year for fear I might
be sad thinking of him I was so wrong
this year for the first time I am
spending actual Christmas Day in New
York City I have brunch plans with
friends tickets to see it's a wonderful
life on the big screen and some plans by
myself because no one is interested in
going on a Christmas bus light tour with
me through Brooklyn the craziest part
I sold a script to the ABC network this
September about a woman who gets dumped
on Christmas I'll be finishing the
script over the holidays in my hotel
room overlooking a Christmas tree in
Bryant Park because I dropped my old
stories I made room for a new one and
there are even more stories to come that
I can't even imagine our story is never
over despite what our worst thinking
tells us Merry Christmas everybody until
next week have fun